far cry games have long been gigantic
open world affairs providing players
with all sorts of things to do from
driving different vehicles to flying
around with wingsuits to hunting animals
as revolutionary gorilla danny rojas all
those options are available to you again
in far cry 6 and more the game is
cluttered with systems from base
building to weapon modding to sending
guerrilla teams on missions in fact far
cry 6 is overwhelmingly
full of stuff while a lot of its ideas
seem interesting on paper in practice
they're easily ignored there's a whole
lot to do plan for and keep in mind at
any given time and a large portion of it
can feel superfluous and overbearing at
best repetitive and dull at worst
you play as dany a super gorilla fighter
and one person army in the battle to
overthrow dictator anton castillo he's
the fascist president of the cuba like
fictional nation of yara exploiting the
nation's poor and disenfranchised for
slave labor to produce cancer wonder
drug viviro castillo got elected on the
promise that viviro would bring wealth
back to yara but he's hoarding all that
wealth and the chemical used to make
viviro is a disastrous poison that kills
yarns in droves that setup basically
acts to free you up to kill anybody with
a military uniform especially the yarn
leadership who are known for their
intense cruelty returning far cry
players will recognize the usual setup a
charismatic but obviously evil villain
you love to hate played here brilliantly
by breaking bad's giancarlo esposito you
are a lion
and we eat the [ __ ] lambs and a cast
of wacky characters who assist you in
taking him down while a few are stoic
and there are some emotional moments
those characters exist mostly for comic
relief to be quirky as they explain how
you're helping them make napalm or joke
around about their love for a
particularly battle-hardened tank you
try this i took one for research now i
can't stop
turn my piss purple you want one no that
creates a whole lot of tonal whiplash
and ultimately undermines what seems to
be the point of far cry 6 which is that
fighting and overarching evil is easy
but building a nation and maintaining
justice is hard you spend a lot of time
talking to clara the leader of the rebel
group who says the real war will start
after castillo is deposed and she
doesn't expect to live to see the better
world she's hoping to create won't
re-election solve that what happened to
your list
it's a vision dany but i'm not as naive
as you think
this revolution will free yara but won't
fix it yara had a revolution before and
then it had another one before the one
you've helped kick off lately and
nobody's life is materially better than
it used to be except for the strong men
who take advantage the characters are
aware that outside political influences
corporate interests and those hungry for
power are waiting in the wings for the
shooting to stop it's a bleak
acknowledgement on top of a bleak
premise and a few times far cry 6 really
gets close to having something
interesting to say about it there's the
corporate president who takes advantage
of you're in poverty to make billions
off the vero who your guerrilla mentor
insists you spare so he can fund your
revolution rather than the regime
there's the major insistent implication
that castillo doesn't just target the
poor and the political but also lgbtq
plus people as well one character
insists that even if he joins up in the
battle against the regime and you win
he'll still be trans in yara and his
revolution will continue when the
fighting stops likely with a lot less
support and there's the repeated
acknowledgment that dany finds all this
bloodshed to be great fun stepping into
the same meta territory explored in far
cry 3 but with a lot less to say about
it the game never really wants to engage
with any of these ideas too deeply and
even after you hit the credits there's a
live game engine at work that'll keep
you fighting the military week after
week as they retake bases and
checkpoints you've already liberated far
cry 6 wants to say something about
something but it's not really sure what
and it never really finishes its point
when you finally hit the what now part
of actually trying to make a free
country out of yara dany very pointedly
just walks out of the room
anyway the usual far cry loop continues
as you kindle the flames of revolution
you'll attack military checkpoints and
bases and capture them for liver tat
your freedom fighter outfit while
completing story missions that are
mostly about gathering more forces to
libertad's cause and taking out
castillo's lieutenants the open world
map is littered with things to do along
the way and in order to build your
arsenal of freedom fighting gear you'll
need to stop frequently to seek out
military caches to unlock new guns and
new clothes with specific perks for
specific situations like resisting
poison or scavenging crafting materials
early on guerrilla mentor juan cortez
tells you to make sure you bring the
right tool for the right job and that's
central to what far cry 6 is pushing in
its gameplay the idea here is that you
want to scan enemies ahead of a fight to
find out what bullets are most effective
against them and what weapons they have
and adjust your loadout but there are a
lot of guns and a lot of mods and a lot
of clothes to the point where
customization often feels way too broad
in addition to guns you can modify
yourself there are also unique weapons
you can find all over yara that have
special combinations of perks for
specific uses and then there are the
resolver weapons which are similar to
the cobbled together weird weapons of
far cry new dawn one's a flamethrower
one's a harpoon gun that sticks people
to walls one's a sniper rifle that fires
a big explosive round and so on
despite all these options i found the
first rifle i got with the
armor-piercing rounds that cut through
kevlar helmets and a crappy but workable
suppressor was effective through a vast
majority of the game outside of the big
fights of some story missions a lot of
the time you can just sneak around and
headshot everyone with the same gun
especially because enemies are mostly
pretty stupid
[Music]
you have this whole mess of tools but
the pool of options is so big that the
different guns start to feel only
slightly different the enemies and
situations you find yourself in are
largely very similar to one another and
don't demand that much brain power
choices really just come down to what
goofy combination of elements you want
to bring into a fight but if you want to
avoid a fight a series of sneaky
headshots are easy enough to land the
overabundance of choices that saps their
meaning extends to everything instead of
a skill tree or abilities to unlock dany
can purchase supremos special backpacks
that give them what is essentially an
ultimate ability that charges up over
time and as they rack up kills sopranos
include a missile battery a thing that
launches poison bombs a jet pack that
shoots out a ring of fire around you and
a pack that gives you an instant
self-revive if you should get too hurt
but really the missile battery feels
like the best choice most of the time
you'll unlock a bunch of supremos if you
do the work to find the materials you
need to purchase them but you don't
really need them they're just another
bunch of choices you can make as the
fancy strikes you far cry games are best
when situations devolve into ridiculous
chaos and the upshot of all these
choices of weapons and gadgets and mods
is that they can help make chaos happen
in hilarious ways the explosive resolver
sniper rifle brings down helicopters in
a snap and they often crash into places
where they blow up other soldiers or
start fires the missile battery will
track a bunch of soldiers as they run
across the battlefield sending them
flying in all directions the poison
turns enemies against each other to turn
an approaching force into a discordant
bunch of maddened allies and lots of
guns start fires which will burn across
fields and blow up tanks of viviro
poison to make for some great action
movie moments so when far cry 6 is
firing on those cylinders it's a lot of
fun in fact most of the story missions
are pretty engaging and doing things
like air dropping onto a military ship
and taking out its crew or setting a
tobacco field on fire feel as good here
as they have in past iterations of the
series the far cry formula works by and
large and the new additions to it offer
some cool ways to help make nonsense
happen the trouble is that there are so
many things to do
find gather and use laid on top of and
distracting from that core formula even
after more than 30 hours and having
worked through the entire story and most
of the side missions i've still got what
feels like a ludicrous number of
additional things to cross off my list
co-op missions weekly insurrection
missions treasure hunts recruiting new
amigos crafting more guns buying more
supremos adding more vehicles to my
bases chasing unique weapons finding
roosters for a cockfight mini-game
fishing hunting gathering materials to
upgrade my base structures it all feels
like so much more than necessary gumming
up the works of the fun element of
getting into fights and setting things
aflame far cry 6 is often a fun game
that feels like it's throwing everything
at you and if you want a heap of content
it absolutely has you covered in
isolation a lot of its elements are
interesting ideas taken together though
it's a lot of disparate things that keep
taking your attention back to menus and
map icons it's a bunch of exhausting
extra stuff when really what far cry 6
is good at is giving me opportunities to
blow stuff up
[Music]
you